du balai novateur à nier les quatre là
un peu plus la pop star a aligné face à
des noms mais thébaux corse à regarder
vous mettez la merci mais qu'il a envers
sir vient de confier mes lunettes
oui j'ai peur bien sûr je vais tout
allez on y va je te confie l'élu
attention c'est très simple ça s'appelle
le plaquage du poste christian califano
garder la baisse des rentes avs non non
il enlever sa veste
ah non mais oui pour le pour le micro
pour le micro ce paradis va le faire il
va le faire comme ça ta sont ils
planquent raffinage du coup les micros
je vous explique mathieu gilles et doni
et bertrand je vais vous poser des
questions sur la télévision chacun votre
tour c'est que des questions chiffre s
il vous plaît à tuer s'il ya un petit
peu de concentration les questions
chiffre est celui de vous 4 qui sera le
plus loin la bonne réponse de monsieur
dit si tu es loin de la bonne réponse tu
vas en prendre une part christian
califano donne la bonne réponse celui
qui sera la plus loin la bonne réponse
sera plaquée par christian califano
il saura c'est beau non à l'arrêt alors
maintenant mais je vous explique
vous ne savez pas qui sera le plus loin
il va jeter sur quelqu'un vous
comprendra 3 voilà
quand vous êtes plaquer vous êtes
éliminé le dernier debout après trois
questions et vainqueur ok ok attention
première question va démarrer on va
démarrer par verre consommé roi pour les
réponses à jour là les cinq premières
après on fera la avril chaque année
d'après une étude de l'insee réalisée en
combien de temps un français passe t-il
en moyenne devant la télé le dimanche
mais reproche à me revoir très vite
vainqueurs 5 heures vous 3 or 1 3h20
4h42 est bon il est chaud 3h36 course je
fais le monsieur te dit de la plaque et
gilles verdez
mathieu décaler la bonne réponse était
2h51 c'est bertrand qui était plus
l'attention
deuxième question en disant de diffusion
combien de bébés ont vu le jour grâce au
couple formé dans l'amour est dans le
pré vous démarrez de leurs maux ok mal
dans les plans soient aussi est-ce que
je peux revoir la question combien de
bébés dans l'amour est dans le pré
nos plans dit randy saison 6 sinon en 22
32 27
et bercy
les cylons clé dégagé dégagé la piste
les gars du bled dégager la piste
dégagée rapide attention il reste j les
deux voici la question en euros un style
qu'elle aima montant de plus gros gain
remporté par un candidat de questions
pour un champion sur france 3 denis
brogniart 77 mille euros et vous 22 0 22
me en effet attentes et raiden tout la
base il sait pas des gens mais tu peux
lui donner des consignes à aimer le
tapis on est allé vous même
christian allez y mollo je dis juste un
truc des fonds sous
tout le monde
celui-ci